but he's a you know you can see he's a
big guy i'm a big guy and what we're
going to do is we're going to
a technique for mushy and over here
cutter i'm not going to do that you're
going to do that and who else is strong
i know matthew's strong oh you're
so somebody that doesn't know each other
um
hands by the side
all right advice is different techniques
technique is
this
and you know the vest
well he thinks he does
i want you holding a strong
okay
so how would we ever get the fork
theory working here
so so these are the challenges that we
come up against
yeah
that's it good
all right
so
already puffing them up now what a lot
of peculiar what a lot of people do
is this they go like this and they just
you're gonna have to let me do it all
right because i can't
but a lot of people do this you watch
the youtube
this art comes up and they take a thank
you
it's all out there you don't believe me
so they come here
do that they lift it up maintain it
thank you
there's no way
look how much he struggled and he done
it correct
so
you can't lift you do it by turning so
it's a conversion look
of getting his body to escape his body
escaped
you didn't see his hand go over his i've
been watching his videos
and you didn't see his hand go
separate
separate on its own way to ascencion and
now i'm going to ask you to do a saint
pio
so these are our contradictions that we
we find difficult okay
now is he off balance or could he dig in
there he could dig in if you didn't want
to hurt him
all right
so so the lightness once you start
getting involved in these techniques
becomes very difficult it's the ghosts
don't i think
the person who run the hole before he
was one of the helpers he was the
electrical whip wizard and all the
curtains start closing on their own at
certain times
so
it's just to show you really
hate that you cannot
do this unless you're physically strong
but you can go oh i've made myself a
hole
but that's the bit i wanted
so that when you come out you don't have
to take that a second bite of the
technique
hey
yeah
this hand is no good so i gotta do that
my shoulder but what i'm gonna do is i'm
not gonna come out
and now apply the same here
quite a bad shoulder a couple years now
here
it's it's up it's all there and do you
know what he's feeling
all right so i think you've all got
enough information there thank you for
coming i'd like to just uh
say
i i don't really want to do these sort
of workshops even though it's a lot of
information it's far far too advanced
and i'm not trying to be disrespectful
it's far too advanced keep doing
workshops like this
it's a seed
for you to realize
yeah i am digging in but that's the best
i can do for now
but you can retract when we track over
the years trying to lose your strength
learn more about technique
look at your body
i don't know if i was moving or not
enough because i was so busy involved in
doing it
and the same as when you just escaped
i'm out i'm out
you know i've got there
and then you
tweet the technique so it's got to flow
so it's always continuous
it's always